can you believe this this is a
draw this I can believe that it's a draw
but that we reach this position from
from that
overwhelming situation that's insane and
he missed an incredible defensive
resource he was one move away from
winning the game and first I guess we
should wait for the game to
conclude but this is a easy Fortress
draw I would imagine this is this is
kind of Tactical and it will go on
forever so I believe you can just very
quickly show us the the critical moment
what was missed move 34 black move 34
now Magnus was over complicating it
progressively he had easier wins but
here he goes Rook to C3 okay and here
Knight C2 he thinks the game is over
that's it the pawn is promoting what
does he miss he misses Knight D5
suddenly F6 is a weakness The Rook has
to drop back to C6 but it's a vulnerable
square and the Knight circles back to B4
retreating Knight moves are the hardest
moves in chess to see this forces either
a knight trade and then the E Pawn will
be easily stopped by White's Rooks or
Magnus plays Knight takes
A3 and Parham simply trades everything
allows the promotion but at the end the
A7 Pawn Falls and With It Go most of
Black's winning
chances yes okay it's still not over yet
clearly if White's Knight would be on F4
or somewhere solid wow F4 no I'm not
liking this what is this F4 move it
might still be D but it gives black this
route with his King to enter I hate this
I very much wanted to just go Knight B4
Knight DC Knight F4 and then you just
sit besides the H5 Pawn was a big Target
yeah KN that you push the pawn F4 no
this F4 is a horrible
blunder and how is Magnus going to get
that King to White side of the board he
goes Rook D1 he's going to try to
restrict the the Knight and is he going
to start going King E6 King D5 King
E4 yes because the point is that King E6
run into Knight D4 check that was the
the defensive resource but yeah luk D1
is super impressive making sure that the
Knight is not able to and Parham will
lose this you think Parham will lose
this yes he will lose this but what if
he F4 was a terrible it will be a very
costly
mistake let's see how the game
progresses we've got more moves they'll
be coming in
momentarily yes and everything according
to plans yeah luk D1 play King F3 King
E6 Magnus getting that chance he will
use
it incredible so instructive looks like
param has this E5 Square for his Knight
but it will not prevent the black king
from infiltrating via the light squares
King D5 and King E4 they're blitzing out
the
moves obviously it's not the ideal
camera angle but looks like Magnus
already has played King D5 there we go
beautiful this is perfect yeah yeah
param going Knight F7 Knight G5 he wants
to make sure that the Knight controls
but this this should not hold this
should not hold slowly step by step if
black king reaches E3 yeah if somehow
the king reaches E3 then there will be
no defense against the GC on the GC Pawn
in a long run the Knight on G5 is out of
the game but how to get that A7 maybe I
thought he gives a check and now Rook A7
forcing the Knight onto E5 then he will
give the check on A3 and infiltrate with
King E4 Knight G5 trying to stop the
king from infiltrating but
KN yeah because actually with r ah okay
you can always go back with the King to
F2 and then Knight F3 but yeah
King maybe okay how
exactly okay King D4 King d four in goes
the
king maybe a check on E6 can be
considered yeah but okay King D3 and
then King D2 King E1 that's why this F5
F4 construction that white can never
trade pawns yeah normally that's one of
the key strategy that you keep the pawn
on F3 and you always have G4 to to get
rid of Pawns if if necessary now in this
construction you can never do that
exactly we hardly see Magnus on the
camera but it's enough from his hand
movement body movement to feel that he
he senses that yeah this should be
winning and and look at the body
language and the hand movement are very
firm and what relief he must feel King
D3 inching forward but param refusing to
die knight6 obviously cannot miss a
fork and he's trying to go through D2
and D1 I
think yes but okay this Knight on G5 and
the Knight is still jumping it's also
very irritating that it looks like it
should be already a win and then your
open and has a kind of a good defensive
the that's also very
frustrating wow magu setting up a trap
yeah that with Knight G7 white can
attack both pawns but black is very
happy to give one of them with King E4
and then the king eventually reaching
the FC
Square
exactly yeah that Knight on H5 it's the
worst Square on the
board I'm trying to make some moves on
my screen so that maybe I can at some
point show
something yes now we have the now we
have the live
board with Luke A1 lot of tension on
Parham Knight C5 check
oh careful King D4 Knight B3 would have
been quite a tragic result but of course
Magnus very carefully
zigzagging and Knight E6 wow is param
surviving
this it could easily be yeah because now
practically it's uh kind of very
difficult for black to to make
progress
now ahuh I was think think maybe you
want the Rook on B1 so that there's no
Fork on B3 but the crazy thing is even
if you play King D3 Knight C5 King
D2 where are you going from there he
goes back to
D5
yes Knight G5 again back to home
base yeah the Knight on G5 is
beautifully protecting the E4 entry
square and the King by going King F3
King F2 making sure that the E3 square
is kind of Tabo black is not able to get
there L A6 back okay correct King E3 K
E3 stopping the king from entering
report mlov was a draw by the way and
this is the pivotal game Magnus back to
C4 trying to find the right construction
here Knight F7
again amazing yeah nerve-wracking
because it only takes one mistake from
White side and then the game will be
over but how to Magnus is trying to
provoke Knight to E5 yes but param
doesn't want to play Knight E5 he wants
to actually keep the Knight on F7 it's
such a paradox Peter that in some of
these end games you don't want the
Outpost it's not about the Outpost it's
about controlling the right
squares yes yes the E4 square is is kind
of the key Square that's why Parham is
always jumping in a way that he is able
to control it King F2
played King
D3
yes and Knight wow knight5 why Knight E5
but he goes back to
F7 and he might be just in time just in
time where is
he wow my glance
this is too deep for me okay you need uh
you need also nerves of Steel to be
handling and param seems to be believing
already that he has find the foress we
have seen that moment when Magnus was
believing with his with his movement
that yes I G to get it and now I feel
like param is signaling that all right I
got it this is a draw I got my
Fortress yeah he might feel that Magnus
has exhausted all of his ideas but
something tells
me he hasn't exhausted them just yet
look at the opposition stopping the
penetration to E1 King D1 check there
might be king F1 incredible just like a
pend game yeah that's uh that's kind of
stunning will he dare to play the move
King F1 that's a big question it's not
an easy move psychologically to make no
definitely not but if you move up
there's King E1 and that's a whole yes
new can of worms that you've opened
exactly and with King F3 King E1 King F1
r a checkmating threat also yes Magnus
making that typical Carlson waiting move
throwing the ball back at Parham saying
hey you make a
move yeah making a move is always the
toughest yes in such
situations Knight
E6
just in case hinting at Knight D4 yeah
double
attack but that's also kind of yes okay
now Rook C5 is is running into another
fork with Knight B3 check one needs to
be
careful Magnus might as well try King D1
check but after King F1 already Knight
G7 oddly enough becomes a problem and
black could end up losing his Pawns
yes it's already even after King D1 I'm
not completely sure if King FC is not
possible because exactly due to the
Knight G7 kind of
idea Magnus running out of time running
out of winning attempts back to D3 he
goes back he need to accumulate yeah he
needs to accumulate
time but Knight G7 would be a huge
mistake here I think because if King D4
check and King
E4 baram correctly keeps his Knight on
E6 so that he can give that check on G5
as soon as the king reaches
E4 yes and this G5 square is the the key
Square yeah that you can never enjoy the
E4 Square because white will be
kicking that King away
instantly Rook C6 Knight
G5 there was this mistake by parhan with
F4 but ever since
the defense he's showing is just
incredible and he's got plenty of time
on his clock I mean you can sense the
confidence he doesn't even need the two
minutes he's got timour G by the way has
defeated Nial sarin he's got four out of
four and off we go Rook A6 Knight
F7 yeah he simply feels and believes
that this is a mechanism and since
Magnus is also unable to make any
progress it's logical to to think like
this but yeah
Magnus will never give up he will
pretend like okay I'm giving up but he's
only waiting for that one week moment of
his opponent to capitalize on his
chances yeah he's like the nine headed
Hydra you cut off one head another one
takes its place trying to find the
trickiest construction trying to force
this Knight off sides but param has
found the right waiting Square the
Knight sits on F7 for as long as it can
as soon as black plays King E4 you give
the check on
G5 and that is why Magnus is trying to
provoke the Knight onto an awkward
square but baram doesn't
budge okay he went for Knight D6 he
shows some
guts oh
sa oh yes Magnus had enough he wants to
get the king to E4 at all cost even if
it means I'm
another one but Knight F5 King E4 is a
disaster for white because the Rook
comes into
D2 so Knight what but what did param do
he had two minutes on the clock why is
he rushing with Knight
D6 and Sh is this he forgot about Rook
D7 but I think Knight E8 might hold
on no Knight Knight's over no it's over
yeah Knight d8 but then
but then
what well then already you find the win
it's uh it's impossible to it's
impossible to hang on with a knight on
E8 it's it's crazy he's trying yeah and
he traps it the Knight is out of oxygen
the Knight is
trapped King F3 I think has to be tried
but now the king can just walk back and
trap the Knight it's over oh my gosh
this is what we have have been talking
and it's typical kind of trick yeah and
you feel like it's a draw then you look
around like you have given up on your
hopes and then one mistake play too
quickly by open and then you jump on the
chance wow absolutely incredible this
guy is a magician yeah King D4 such a
powerful idea you just casually Waltz
back the Victory lap and the black king
is going to do the honors Knight C7 but
the Knight does not Escape past the
seventh rank A6 and E6 are held by The
Rook it's
over yeah the king is going back to D7
yeah King C5 Knight C7 Knight C7 yeah
that's what I wanted to highlight that
is there a square which we have to pay
attention or is it already automatic
Magnus taking his time but wait King C5
Knight C7 I'm not seeing exactly how you
trap the
Knight
H Rook C6 I go back to E8 that's the
problem
oh yeah not so easy
to because I don't have the last move
still I don't know which POS aha okay
this is the
position I think I see a win with Rook
C6 but it's very convoluted
four
seconds the
Knight back to a
ohing like
this
unbelievable and Knight C7 back oh and
King B6 and there's another Fork knight8
Rook e six that's 8 King B7 this is
exquisite he goed the King on to E3 now
Knight E8 Rook E6 and Parham is going to
resign
unreal wow but interesting what uh what
is
param asking
there and look at this Magnus is also
laughing that what happened
here not totally sure ah hang on ah
maybe Paran because param did not resign
yeah he did not he asked the Arbiter to
check for maybe 50 moves or something
but it won't be enough absolutely not no
way move yeah that's why Magnus is
laughing yeah because smiling he knows
exactly that he does not have to worry
about what param is trying to achieve
here it's close Peter it's very close F4
was move
43 this is move 87 so bar like five
moves
away yes unable he he sensed it uh but
also kudos to him yeah one could be here
completely shocked and just resign and
run away but he has to maximize his
chances to try to survive this game yeah
imagine if it would exactly be correct
yeah it would be a fantastic
move amazing for for newer players
watching who might be puzzled 50 move
roll means if there are 50 moves made
without a pawn move and without a
capture you can claim a draw and there
have been some incredible instances
where a piece is lost on the 50th move
and one way or the other either you
claim the draw or a player misses it by
just one move here par misses it by five
or six
moves I can't believe what we just saw
yeah yeah it's it just shows that yeah
chess is incredible game there are so
many angles yeah that uh even when it
looks like param almost uh I mean that
he has to design he still still has a
chance but unfortunately we know that
it's it's not
enough and for those people saying
Parham is a sore loser he absolutely is
not he's actually an incredibly gracious
person you have to try everything right
what if this had turned out to be mo50
what would you do in his shoes you have
to try every last trick this is a
completely legitimate request by Parham
unfortunately for him he's going to wind
up short yes and imagine that if it
would be yeah that's it handshake param
designs wow